Adam Carolla the comedian radio
personality TV host actor podcaster
director he joins us now Merlin Olsen
just to bring it into full football was
obviously in Little House of the Prairie
yeah so that gives it a football theme
well I'm trying to think of those
athletes who Trent you know they
transition they crossed over into
something you know Fred dryer was able
to do that Alex Karras was he Alex might
have been the first with Webster wasn't
he or was Merlin owes me for him Blazing
Saddles well you know Alex Karras did
yeah Blazing Saddles Merlin did hunter
you know I mean not Merlin uh Fred dryer
right dryer was was hunter and there's a
few a Joe Namath they'd like C&C fun
factory or whatever C&C and son he was a
biker every starting a beatnik biker
movie Joe Namath did and whatever and
Deacon Jones didn't get a lot of acting
work but oh man if you guys want to see
a trailer I mean you guys love this
stuff the man with two heads rosey Grier
and like George Peppard or something we
we do you see do you see this trailer
your head will explode like you'll go oh
my god what did we we never did that we
made this movie just bully me
the thing with two heads there's two
guys on a motorcycle jumping a flaming
thing it's rosey Grier Don Marshall man
just play the beginning just at the
beginning just to blow your mind your
your we're gonna find it find it play
the trailer you're your official
introduction Adams not Taco Bell
material film is now available on
chassis calm that's a chass why also a
couple of documentaries that you're
doing when we went mad and meme gods
those are your your movie yeah MADtv is
making a Doc's I make documentaries
when about Paul Newman in his racing
life I made one that they're gonna make
a movie out of the 24-hour war that's
Ford versus Ferrari at Lamar doing that
new one with Christian Bale and Matt
Damon and Matt Damon's playing Carol
Shelby and blah blah blah and I'm making
a Carol Shelby doc so and it's LeMond no
Moll do you say Porsche or Porsche well
here's an interesting thought on portion
Porsche some people say well in Germany
say Porsche in the United States you
could say Porsche but it's a guy's name
so if you think about it you wouldn't
say is it mr. Magoo or mr. Magoo it's
mr. Magoo like it is Porsche is the name
of the guy so why would you screw around
with pronouncing but we see merrily
Jaguar and Jaguar yeah but that's not a
guy's name and that's could be like you
know you know the war hey Jaguar he's a
gardener but he drives a luxury
automobile
there is Carnegie like Carnegie Hall and
then there's a generous grant from the
Carnegie Foundation but that's just PBS
you know doing whatever you're you guys
seen the man with two heads yeah I
watching the trailer we're gonna play it
right it's it's it's mind-numbing I got
a couple of things to ask you about here
and I guess the Dennett's were
fascinated by the fact that you don't
have a middle name and that you gave
yourself a middle name now is that your
official middle name is Lakers was was
your official middle name on your
driver's license Lakers yes it is it
still yes it's on all documents ever
deeds and certificates okay walk me
through that day when you say honey I've
got my middle name and now I gotta go
change money so I was never had a middle
name I wasn't excited about
having middle name but it not because I
needed a middle name but my parents were
pretty lazy fair in terms of raising
their kids and I felt like this was part
and parcel of them raising their kids
like we don't need a middle name so
whatever here these guys worth like 13
middle names I get so little Dakota
satchel you know look alright so I had
no middle name and when you have no
middle name constantly there's a box in
the middle when you're filling out
paperwork and it mocks you it's like
what is your middle name and the answer
is my parents didn't care enough to
bestow me with the middle name one year
I was at the DMV probably like 85 I
think the Celtics and the Lakers were
you know right in the heart of the
Celtics Lakers Bird Magic world
Kareem and everything else and I was at
the DMV and I was filling out some
paperwork and there was the middle box
mocking me and I just looked at it I was
thinking about the Lakers and the right
in the middle of the playoffs and blah
blah blah and I just wrote Lakers into
that box and then I just turned it in
and from that day forth it's been on
every contract every piece of license
you know Burt it's it's not on my birth
certificate but it is unlike passports
and in every official thing it'll be on
my tombstone
are you a Laker fan okay in the 80s it
was great to be like yeah I might change
it to clipper I you know I should have
went to the DMV like every several years
and done you know Chicago Bulls and then
moved on to Golden State and just you
know been Fairweather Grizzlies
Grizzlies Memphis let me say Oh tell me
about not Taco Bell material it's a
stand-up special it's my first stand-up
special it's a semi-autobiographical and
that is jokes stand-up and all that but
we also go through my life I also take
you through I put my Social Security
Statement up there all the money you've
ever earned your entire life if you guys
ever got
100 you it starts in high school you
made 234 dollars like that year and it
just keeps going and going going we go
from no money no money
you know $5,000 and 1991 and like just
struggle struggle struggle - when I met
Jimmy Kimmel and then hundreds of
thousands and then millions of dollars
so it's a it's inspirational
what's the most you have remained in a
year yeah I I don't know exactly I said
probably five billion dollars maybe when
did you feel rich
I don't feel rich I feel like I and I'm
not
I'll tell you who's rich my wife and my
kids are ready I'm a donkey that goes
out and and brings back money they are
rich they live a life that's
extraordinary I live a life or just go
out play the club get paid come back fly
south twice go to the other place I
swear to you they're rich ask them well
what would their reaction be if you came
back and said I'm retiring oh I don't
know they'd someone would have to go get
remarried or have sexual reassignment
surgery and remarry or do something
because there oh listen there's nothing
look I've said this to my wife a million
times like I said look I'm gonna go to
Wichita I'm gonna go to DeKalb Illinois
I'm gonna go to Wisconsin I'm gonna do a
show I'm gonna come home and you're
gonna be at home and you're gonna be
eating sushi and and you're gonna do
that move where you've invited three or
four your friends out and when the bill
comes around you go oh no no no no no I
got this and I'm like I'm in which time
dancing to pay for the sushi and I've
said this and I don't know if you guys
think this is horrible or not but I said
luck I go out on stage I do 90-minute
shows I sweat my ass off
I'm just saying during that 90 minutes
instead of spending my money could you
be
home just running in place you know what
I mean just during that and then look I
get it 90 minutes is a long time for her
just to run in place but didn't do
pushups done I mean our jumping jacks
just something to say what if she has
her trainer over to then help her do all
of this well that's now that's costing
me money and there's a sexual component
and now I'm just finding the man with
two heads
it's the greatest thing ever I was
curious up my my high school got rid of
the valedictorian they just had it it's
like two weeks ago they don't have a
valedictorian anymore and everybody's
worried about the effects on kids and
where you're ranked and all of those
things I'm curious what you think of my
high school little Mason High School in
Cincinnati where we don't have Valentich
valedictorian anymore because we don't
want to embarrass people and have
rankings what's crazy is if you look if
you go back long enough and you look at
some old yearbook stuff in there like if
you're running for the Supreme Court and
someone gets your yearbook and they want
to look up some stuff you see stuff like
when I was in junior high we had
best-looking best-looking male but we
had best body and best physique of 14
year old girl and dolphin shorts and a
sports bras like what I mean we had the
bet it wasn't we didn't come from North
Hollywood we didn't put an emphasis on
brains but if you if you look good in
shorts you you're going places but we I
I got class clown we had like smartest
most like we did everything we had best
eyes best hair I mean we got really I'm
from LA like maybe it's super static
most likely to be bedded by a producer
[Laughter]
now it's on an official category no but
it was you had the best body
you knew that was around the corner but
I know I but didn't you like once I was
a kid when we were younger
yet you know best body
yes she had the best body and he had the
best body we had most athletic yeah like
that guy was super athletic her we had
most likely to succeed or valedictorian
we're like yeah they get old they pull
all grace like yeah why it wasn't
shocking or hurtful
it wasn't demoralizing yeah but we got
to this point where it just feels like
now not one person can win everybody has
to win right and I have a sad part of it
I'm okay I I'm gonna lose the I may lose
this Sports Emmy tonight yeah but it
doesn't mean that everybody gets
nominated and we all go up on the stage
and we all share in this big group who
got nominated there's a show that's
going to win tonight
and it I'm okay with that it obviously
means nothing when everybody is a winner
everybody is whatever
it's insane so my son ran cross country
for a while when he was like eight years
old and at the end of the meet he came
in like 9th place and I said to my wife
okay let's go like my my entire I don't
cheer for my son I yell at my wife can
we go now we can go now right which is
wrapped up he comes in ninth I said can
we go she said no no they're doing the
metal ceremony the metal ceremony they
said nice he said there's a podium
there's three things on it no no I said
listen first off the guy next to him is
gonna be standing on a cookie sheet
it's gonna be standing in a hole because
he came in ninth place and she's like
but he gets a medal and I do not believe
but all these do all it does is make all
these guys into horrible employees who
later on in life believe me I employ
some of these guys it's a disaster my
daughter ran cross-country in high
school and she wasn't very good so my
wife and I said hey don't finish last
and she said don't put so much pressure
on me Wow yeah cuz she would either
finish second to last or last so we had
to stay there for the whole time and her
and wait for her to come in and
meanwhile there are kids that were there
for
our just waiting and they'd you know
they were ready to go home so I I
understand that pain but your son
finished ninth yeah like that's that's
damn good we are at a seven guys those
know you guys want with me in this it
when we do the real marathon you know
the Kenyan guys come in first and in
blah blah blah but you know the guys who
really come in first like an hour before
everyone else the guys with the
souped-up wheelchairs right those guys
Kevlar and they're running you know
sealed bearings and blah blah blah
and look it's fine but they're finishing
an hour before the canyons what if we
just put them in standard wheelchairs
you know what I mean like the kind you
know when your wife gets this discharge
from the hospital after the c-section
and they just wheeler to the front door
what if they had to run it in those
wouldn't that be more exciting like at
the end when the Kenyan guy turns the
corner and the guy with the whatever it
is I don't see those guys in a rocket
ship and it's called a marathon how
about you put the wheelchairs in with
the Kenyans right that's what yeah and
then we then we see sort of same but the
other way they cannot be they can't have
a spaceship they need something standard
during the commercial break we're gonna
show you this the thing with two heads
oh we're gonna play you you guys will
never stop thanking me he's Adam Carolla
the film is now it's called not Taco
Bell material it's on chassis chass
why.com and you can get it on iTunes and
Amazon andand a great stand-up special
and a couple of documentaries on chassis
media we went mad and meme god it's
always great to see you
we hate you a stopping by he's Adam
Corolla for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]